what's the most expensive problem that's
happened with one of your exotic cars
five manual Murcielago was unfortunately
crashed on a test drive by the service
shop manager how many of those cars are
still in existence there were only like
23 in North America how did it get
crashed they were test driving the car
while it was still winter and so when
the snow melts even though it's dry
there's this sand all over the road
murcielagos have a really tall first
gear got on it lots of power my car was
converted to rear wheel drive wasn't
all-wheel drive that game kicked out
sent them sideways and just luck of the
draw hit The One pole on the whole
street tore the whole car apart how
expensive was the fix I have a million
dollars